[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend
donnerstagabend es klasse dass sie mit
dabei sind das sind unsere gäste und
hier ist unser thema rund
133.000 menschen haben sich gestern mit
corona angesteckt darunter prominente
wie handball nationalspieler nicht
prominente omikron kann einfach jeden
treffen allen wünsche ich natürlich gute
besserung und den schon sprichwörtlichen
läden verlauf aber gibt es bei aller
sorge auch echten grund zur hoffnung
könnte das thema corona bald nicht nur
für diese infizierten erledigt sein
sondern für uns alle ist am mikro noch
eine chance oder freuen wir uns wieder
einmal zu früh mit omikron leben konzept
oder kapitulation das fragen wir uns und
diese gäste
markus söder der bayerische
ministerpräsident sagte vorsicht jahr
aber keine hysterie
anna klaus die spiegel journalisten
stellt fest dieses augenmaß hat söder
bisher immer abgelehnt
clemens wenn der chefarzt an der klinik
münchen schwabing sagt zu den verläufen
bild heißt nicht gleich harmlos
franziska giffey für berlins regierende
bürgermeisterin ist die situation in der
hauptstadt ernst und es gibt zu wenig
pcr tests
und jonas schmidt chanasit
der virologe sagt in großbritannien
nimmt die omikron welle wieder ab das
kann man demnächst auch hier erwarten
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner und
die begrüßt die gäste dieser sendung
ausgesprochen herzlich einen schönen
guten abend und schon geht es los zur
nikon gibt es gute nachrichten und
schlechte viele hören was sie hören
wollen aber es ist ein bisschen
kompliziert
omikron vermehrt sich rasend schnell
auch hier im fast durchgehend bremen
aber erkrankungen verlaufen bei omikron
meldet ist die pandemie bald zu ende zur
lockerung der quarantäne sagt charité
virologe christian drosten
wir reißen das tor ja nicht komplett auf
aber wir müssen an einigen stellen diese
tür jetzt ein bisschen weiter öffnen für
das virus und können und dürfen das auch
weil diese erkrankung in einer geimpften
bevölkerung doch nicht mehr die
krankheit schwerer hat omikron stimmt
rosten optimistisch
es wäre eine chance
breite immunität vorausgesetzt
[Musik]
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach versteht drosten warnt aber
vor fehlschlüssen
der glaube dass die omikron variante das
ende der pandemie ist ist naiv
und wir schalten nach münchen da ist uns
clemens wentner e zugeschaltet chefarzt
der infektiologie münchen klinik
schwabing wir haben eher herr wendler
einen guten abend von karl lauterbach
gehört dass omikron nicht die letzte
mutation sein wird das ist bitter und
deprimierend aber realistisch
also ich glaube man muss sagen wir
wissen noch zu wenig über omikron wir
wissen auch noch zu wenig über
letztendlich technische verlaufe die
krankheit schwerer hatten wir gerade im
beitrag gesehen wird als leichter
eingeschätzt 0 5% hospitalisierung skate
allerdings ist es so dass wir auch einen
virus haben das sehr viel infektiöses
das heißt die geringere krankheit
schwere wird aufgewogen doch die
massiven fallzahlen sie hatten es
erwähnt
133.000 neue fälle und es ist aus meiner
sicht nicht auszuschließen dass wir nach
omikron auch durchaus andere varianten
haben piero sigma wir haben sozusagen
das griechische alphabet noch vor uns
und ich mahne ein wenig zur vorsicht wir
sind hier noch im blindflug jonas
schmidt-chanasit ist bei uns virologe
vom bernhard nocht institut hamburg wie
konnte es eine chance sagt christian
lind christian linder sollen christian
drosten natürlich wenn auch unter einer
kondition unter einer harten bedingungen
nämlich dass es eine breite
immunisierung in der bevölkerung gibt
welche voraussetzungen müssen wir also
schaffen damit ist eine chance ja da hat
christian drosten vollkommen recht wenn
das virus auf geimpfte oder genesene
trifft dann ist die situation so dass es
eben unwahrscheinlicher wird dass es
eine überlastung der kliniken
und auch der intensivstation kommt und
diese mikrowelle überstanden ist müssen
wir uns also ganz genau anschauen wie
dieser immunität status in der
bevölkerung ist also wie viele menschen
sind geimpft und wie viele menschen sind
genesen diese zahlen muss man natürlich
zusammenrechnen das ist nicht richtig
nur die geimpften zu zählen und dann
kann man auf grundlage dieser daten die
dann hoffentlich vorhanden sind
entscheiden ob wir die phase der ende
mai erreicht haben weil meines erachtens
ist das jetzt die endphase der pandemie
nach der mikrowelle so wie sie sich auch
den anderen ländern darstellt und darum
diskutieren ja auch die anderen länder
letztendlich die maßnahmen wie die
weiter fortgeführt werden sollen werden
wir uns diese frage auch stellen müssen
ich hoffe dass wir das bald in den
nächsten wochen denn auch tun wie lange
muss man dann noch abwarten frage noch
mal nach münchen zu herrn wentner karl
lauterbach
bereist ja dass wir mitte februar eben
nennenswert sechsstellig infizierte
haben werden glauben sie denn dass sich
das irgendwie auf den intensivstationen
dann doch widerspiegelt oder gehen sie
auch davon aus dass es eben bei diesen
milden verläufen bleibt
also momentan sieht es so aus dass wir
mehr patienten auf normalstation
versorgen im vergleich zu den zur
intensivstation ungefähr zwei drittel
ein drittel
aber da ist noch nicht das letzte wort
gesprochen
wir wissen dass die intensivpatienten
später kommen das heißt die erkrankung
schwere schlägt später durch und ich
erwarte dass die omikron welle auch eher
richtung februar mit der ende februar
mit voller wucht da sein wird ich sehe
keine gründe warum wir nicht ähnlich
hoch fällt sein wie italien und
frankreich erleben müssen leider aber
als arzt und wissenschaftler ist mein
fokus dass wir ein gesundheitssystem
auch sozusagen krisen festhalten und wir
dürfen es nicht überfordern und deswegen
bin ich mit meinen äußerungen auch
vorsichtig fast sozusagen den verlauf
angeht ich gehe hier vom schlechteren
von der schlechteren variante aus auf
die bereite ich mich als arzt form dann
ist es doppelt interessant für die
politik auch diese beiden
wissenschaftlichen meinungen zu hören
bei unseres franziska giffey die
regierende bürgermeisterin von berlin
vor gefällt die hört sich natürlich
überhaupt nicht toll an berlin mitte
eine zweitausender inzidenz in berlin
insgesamt über 1.000 wie hoch dürfen die
zahlenden seien nach ihrer meinung
ändern alle roten ampeln angehen das
entscheidende ist dass sie sehr hier
auch schon angesprochen worden dass
unser gesundheitssystem nicht überlastet
wird wir haben uns genau angeschaut es
ist jeden tag an wie die belastung auf
den intensivstationen aussieht sie ist
unter 20 prozent und die auch die
hospitalisierung sein sind nicht
vergleichbar mit dem letzten jahr und
wir sehen eben ja wir haben hohe
fallzahlen aber die verläufe sind eben
anders und wir haben viel mehr geimpfte
menschen wir sind jetzt bei fast 80
prozent erstimpfung wir haben
wahrscheinlich übermorgen über die
hälfte der berlinerinnen und berliner
gebucht hat und das sind ganz andere
voraussetzungen und deswegen muss man
auch andere maßnahmen ergreifen
die quarantäne regeln sind geändert ich
bin der meinung dass man jetzt auch das
thema kontakt nachverfolgung und das
thema test regime auch verändern muss
anhand der neuen lagen die wir haben so
und das ist ja hochinteressant wie viel
kann man zu lassen ist die nächste frage
eben weil die menschen geimpft sind wie
sie sagen und weil es einen milderen
verlauf gibt aber auch weil wir im
grunde scheitern weil die kontakt
nachverfolgung ist durch die
gesundheitsämter schlicht nicht mehr
möglich ist es die kontakte nach
verfolgung ist schon möglich aber sie
müssen sie fokussieren sie können eben
nicht jeden einzelnen kontakt nach
verfolgen sondern es gibt der stufen
pläne und die sagen wenn die fallzahl so
hoch ist dass nicht mehr alle kontakte
nachverfolgt werden können muss man sich
konzentrieren auf die variablen gruppen
auf die kritische infrastruktur die
krankenhäuser die pflegeeinrichtungen
die kitas die schulen das ist das was
man realistischerweise machen kann und
ansonsten geht es einfach darum maß vor
jetzt vorzugehen und anhand der neuen
lage dafür zu sorgen dass vor allen
dingen unsere kritische infrastruktur
aufrecht
weshalb wir haben ein monitoring
eingerichtet wo wir das wirklich uns
sehr genau täglich anschauen was da
passiert und wir können bis zu zwischen
20 und 30 prozent ausfall managen wir
sind jetzt bei etwa 15 prozent aus
werden wir uns nachher noch präziser
erkundigen zugeschaltet auch aus münchen
ist uns der ministerpräsident des
freistaates bayern markus söder und wir
fangen der söder an mit ihnen in der
erste frage zu generieren indem wir uns
nochmal anschauen wie sie eigentlich als
selbst ernannter
mannschaftskapitän des teams vorsicht
dann heute agieren und
interessanterweise ist das nicht zum
ersten mal so dass sie offensichtlich zu
augenmaß übergehen wie sie nun sagen
november 2020 die zahl der toten schnell
auf über 400 am tag
markus söder in der runde der
ministerpräsidenten
wir dürfen keine zeit verlieren
die todeszahlen sind aktuell so hoch als
würde jeden tag ein flugzeug abstürzen
markus söder ist der frontmann im team
vorsicht vier monate später wechselt
söder das lager kündigt lockerungen an
obwohl die inzidenz hoch sind fakten
sind dass viele unserer menschen am
limit sind sie sind nicht nur einfach
ermüdet sie sind genervt gestresst doch
schon ende märz nach der misslungenen
oster rohr fordert söder eine notbremse
mit erfolg ungeduld darf nicht unser
schwäche werden ist ihm vorsicht hat
insgesamt sich durchgesetzt und zwar bei
allen zur bundestagswahl gibt sich der
bayer dann wieder locker
ähnliche todeszahlen wie wir sie bei den
anderen wellen zu befürchten haben würde
es nicht geben daher wird es jetzt auch
keinen definitiv keinen lockdown mehr
geben doch delta kommt und führt zu
schweren erkrankungen
söder spielt wieder im team vorsicht das
gesundheitssystem wird nicht mehr lange
halten ist droht ein kollaps ist droht
zu jahr zum auftakt des
landtagswahlkampfes im januar gibt sich
der ministerpräsident dann wieder milde
und er findet ein neues team omikron ist
nicht älter ist eine andere
herausforderung deswegen bleibt bayern
weiter im team vorsicht aber auch im
team augenmaß
vorsicht ja aber keine hysterie und auch
keine panik so einfach ist das
willkommen im team augenmaß
herr söder sie haben gesagt sie haben
recht ich lange nachgedacht aber sie
sind schon ganz schön hin und
hergesprungen in der letzten zeit oder
schön dass sie sich beim irischen guten
anders zu machen schön dass sie sich so
viel mühe geben vermeinte die
widersprüche auch zu zeigen die aber in
der realität durch ein serum sichtliches
und kluges management sich auszeichnen
wir müssen immer auf die situation
reagieren nach empfehlung der experten
das was wir auch hier ja gerade hören
was wir gesagt bekommen sind
unterschiedliche ansichten wie sich
möglicherweise omikron entwickelt das
ist die entscheidende frage jetzt werden
immer reagiert nach empfehlung der
experten dass gerade für die
unterschiedlichen wählen und das gilt
jetzt auch für bekommt denn wenn tommy
grund tatsächlich eine höhere ansteckung
oder milde verläufe hat müssen wir
insbesondere die frage stellen ob es
gerechtfertigt ist das gleiche
management zu machen mit großen eingriff
in die freiheit der menschen und b dann
auch entscheiden ob das noch wirksam ist
oder nicht umgekehrt einen anderen weg
gehen sollen und deswegen glaube ich und
hoffe ich auch dass wir möglicherweise
in omikron trotz der großen
herausforderung ist chancen bleiben aber
dabei dass natürlich die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems nicht passieren darf
da während vorsorge getroffen wir haben
zum beispiel bei uns auch im letzten
herbst stand begonnen mit den
krankenhäusern mit sehr viel geld
investitionen die bayern selbst gemacht
hat die pflegesituation noch mal
deutlich zu verbessern
die betreuung zu verbessern und damit
auch mehr kapazitäten in schwierigen
notfällen zu haben also wir sind darauf
hoffen jedenfalls vorbereitet und müssen
dann umgekehrt sehen wie es weitergeht
gerade bei der entscheidenden frage was
lassen wir zu wasser lassen nicht so ich
glaube dass wir auf romy kunden nicht
allein mit zusperren und allein mit der
strengsten variante reagieren können
müssen sondern wir müssen dann atmen das
system finden das ist auch die
auffassung vieler experten und bis jetzt
stück für stück integrieren anna klausel
ist bei einer journalistin vom spiegel
leitet dort das ressort meinung zusammen
mit einem geschätzten kollegen klasse
dass sie heute abend da sind nikon ist
nicht selten aber söder bleibt söder
also markus söder möchte ja immer an der
spitze der bewegung marschieren und
somit bleibt der syrer in dem er sich
jetzt so schon so ein bisschen an die
spitze derer begibt die jetzt schnell
den notausgang suchen der korona
pandemie aber ich habe mich schon
gewundert als ich ausgerechnet das wort
augenmaß aus herrn sodass mund gehört
hatte war das ein wort das mir von armin
laschet bekannt war also der hatte schon
ziemlich früh zu beginn der pandemie
2020 muss das gewesen sein im frühjahr
war einer der ersten der lockern wollte
und er hatte das immer mit augenmaß
begründet und damals wurde er noch
verlacht gut jetzt ist natürlich eine
andere situation des virus ist mutiert
er ist ja klar dass natürlich auch die
strategie von einem wie markus söder der
ohnehin als politisches chamäleon
bekannt ist mutiert ja aber ich frag
mich halt ob das medizinische gründe hat
oder vielleicht auch mehr politisch
politische und vielleicht eben auch
immer der erste sein zu wollen das mag
ein motiv sei ein politiker kann
natürlich dazu lernen erst recht wenn es
dafür gute gründe gibt angesichts dieser
jüngsten umfragen der bayern und der
beliebtheitswerte auch der bayerischen
landesregierung
glauben sie die bayern nehmen dass ihre
ministerpräsidenten noch
die umfrage von der sie sprechen die
sagt ja dass die regierungsmehrheit der
csu mit den freien wählern gerade wenn
jetzt gewählt werden würde futsch wäre
das sind natürlich dramatisch prozent
genau das sind natürlich dramatische
umstände und die müssen ja markus söder
besorgen und klar wenn er vorhat so
langsam in den wahlkampf modus zu kommen
2023 wird gewählt in bayern und wenn er
so wie in letzter zeit den grünen gerne
vorwerfen möchte dass sie verbots partei
sei dann kann er selber ja nicht den
bürgern in bayern in der korona pandemie
die daumenschrauben weiter anziehen
deswegen glaube ich auch dass
auch deshalb lockerungen sicher
attraktiv sind wie warum sind sie so
sicher herr söder frage zurück zu ihnen
nach münchen dass es im angesicht noch
mal dessen was karl lauterbach schätz
nämlich das mitte februar wir in einer
ganz anderen größenordnung von instanzen
sein können und damit eben auch einer
belastung des gesundheitssystems das
sieht das nicht wieder passieren müssen
was sie jetzt sagen
schauen sie fraglos hat jetzt wie so oft
eine kleine politische betrachtung von
der seitenlinie gemacht die natürlich
zulässig ist ich freue mich auch immer
wieder über die aufmerksamkeit und die
besondere widmung der in frage aber es
geht ja nicht um wahlkampf sondern es
geht um das management in schwierigen
situationen eines aber doch durch corona
gelernt keiner hat die weisheit
gepachtet jede vorhersage hat sich doch
recht schwierig gewesen ich kann mich
erinnern dass auf der einen seite die
fdp und auch die grünen gefordert haben
das ende der pandemischen lage zu
fordern und auch beschlossen haben und
es hat sich gezeigt dass das im grunde
genommen ein schwerer fehler war genauso
wie sich die entwicklungen am ende
völlig verändert haben bei der
einschätzung
dass die jeweilige gefahr betrifft wir
müssen angemessen reagieren immer auf
sich tragen und wir müssen schauen dass
wir mit den experten zusammen regieren
ich habe in der ganzen zeit der pandemie
auf den expertenrat großen wert gelegt
sie haben zu beginn der sendung ich fand
sehr eindrucksvoll professor thorsten
eingespielt wir haben jetzt hier in der
sendung auch gehört unterschiedliche
einschätzungen aber auch eine hoffnung
und wir müssen ja den menschen in diesen
schwierigen zeiten auch diese hoffnung
weitergeben wir können nicht sozusagen
auch verdacht zu sparen sondern müssen
angemessen entscheiden denn die
einschränkung von freiheitsrechten kann
nur dann erfolgen wenn entweder
tatsächlich das gesundheitssystem
zusammenbricht oder eben umgekehrt auch
die situation der krankheitsfälle dafür
deutlich schwieriger ist und ich finde
wer jetzt eine neue situation und zu
einer klugen politik gehört nicht
einfach stur oder ideologisch zu
reagieren oder gar persönlich motiviert
sondern immer das wohl des landes und
der menschen im vordergrund zu rücken da
habe ich glaubt tatsächlich auch
vielleicht man sieht dass exit anderen
ländern können wir darauf hoffen dass am
ende mit omikron vielleicht ein übergang
in eine endemische situation ist ich
würde es nicht versprechen aber ich habe
die hoffnung dass wir diesen weg
vielleicht schaffen und trotzdem es ist
irrsinnig schwierig eben genau auf
dieser basis die sie beschreiben sowohl
schüler als auch vgv nun entscheidungen
zu fällen in berlin frau gefallen sie
haben gerade angedeutet kann diese
kontakt nach verfolgung in einzelnen
bezirken schon nicht mehr erfolgen und
auch stadtbezirke legen für sich fest
dass sie es in den kitas nicht mehr
machen wollen und in den kindergärten
weil man die kinder im grunde genommen
am besten auch nur noch nach ihrem
besten freund fragt und dann nicht die
ganze klasse nach hause schickt also
jetzt irgendwie auch in pragmatismus ein
zu sagen was wir also im grunde ist
regiert der mangel was wir nicht mehr
nachvollziehen können und nicht mehr für
nachverfolgen können lassen wir einfach
weil wir merken dass es nicht zu großen
schäden ich finde es mal ein bisschen
sortieren finde ich gut ja wir werden ab
morgen in allen kitas in berlin
zusätzlich zu den schon bestehenden
testmöglichkeiten die lolli tests
flächendeckend einführen werden dann wie
in der schule reimer die woche die tests
machen wir können also sehr genau und
das test regime in den schulen ist am
genauesten wir haben letzte woche eine
million tests eingesetzt bei in unseren
schulen sehr genau sehen was da passiert
nur welche schlüsse zieht man dann
daraus es ist einfach wichtig dass
tatsächlich maßvoll mit augenmaß wie
auch immer man es nennen mag
gezielt dort kontakte nachverfolgt
werden wo wir
gruppen haben sie besonders
schutzbedürftig sind oder wo es eben
darum geht auch kritische infrastruktur
zu schützen um überall in deutschland
ist die problematik bei solch steigenden
fallzahlen so dass eben nicht mehr alle
kontakte nachverfolgt werden können in
dieser umfänglich kite und das ist auch
anhand der neuen quarantäne regel ja
nicht so viel sinn macht wenn man eben
sagt diejenigen die gepustet sind haben
andere quarantine ringen müssen nicht
mehr als kontaktperson in die quarantäne
gehen dann ist es vielleicht ja auch
nicht unbedingt erforderlich dass man
nun jeden einzelnen kontakt nachverfolgt
es geht darum wirklich zielorientiert
diese kapazitäten die wir dort haben ein
pragmatisch vorzugehen und es ist ja
klar es gibt ja noch ein team in dem
ganzen spiel das team besserwisser
dienen die nachher ist immer besser
wissen und sagen das hätte da aber mal
anders machen sollen ich sehe dass wir
eine große veränderung der lage in den
letzten zwei jahren gesehen haben immer
wieder darauf musste adäquat reagiert
werden und jetzt ist es so dass wir
einfach fallzahlen haben die alles
bisher dagewesene sprengen und das heißt
wir müssen mit anderen mitteln darauf
reagieren aber eins ist auch klar london
kann nicht die antwort sein dafür sind
die krankheitsverläufe nicht so dass sie
das rechtfertigen ich muss ihnen auch
ganz ehrlich sagen ich sehe was das bei
den kindern bewirkt hat als kitas und
schulen geschlossen waren ich werde bis
zum letzten in berlin alles daran setzen
dass wir das nicht noch mal machen wir
haben bei den kindern letzte woche bei
einer million test 0,5 prozent positiv
ergebnisse gehabt das heißt das ist noch
immer so aber sind interessant wird ja
die content nachverfolgung jetzt bei den
erwachsenen stimmt es dass ihre
stadtverwaltung darüber nachdenkt eben
auch die nachverfolgung eben oder
adressen hinterlegung und dokumentation
in bars restaurants gaststätten nicht
mehr zu machen einfach vollkommen
sinnlos und weil sonst nicht
nachvollziehen sind in den diskussionen
natürlich auch mit den anderen
bundesländern darüber ich finde wichtig
dass wir uns da abstimmung dass wir in
vorbereitung auf die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz am montag
dort auch möglichst ein einheitliches
vorgehen verabreden aber es ist ganz
klar wenn man sich dazu entscheidet die
kontakt nach verfolgungs und fokussieren
auf die wohlhabenden gruppen die
krankenhäuser pflegeeinrichtungen kitas
schulen dann bedeutet es dass man an
anderer stelle das dann eben auch nicht
mehr macht und dieser das muss im fokus
gezielt treffen können sich
konzentrieren so und dann sind wir bei
der wissenschaftler schmidt-chanasit ist
das gefährlich zu sagen wir können also
ist es sozusagen fatalistisch zusammen
geschaffen sowieso nicht mehr das
nachzuvollziehen oder sagen sie es ist
im grunde genau ein sehr pragmatischer
weg aus genau den genannten gründen die
geposteten müssen werden ja sowieso
nicht mehr in quarantäne
steckt und anderes mehr ist das
verantwortbar ja also es ist genau der
richtige weg zu legen folgt beschrieben
hat es ist ja auch letztlich eine frage
der effizienz
effektiv wäre es natürlich wenn wir uns
alle zu hause einsperren aber das macht
eben diese massiven schäden die wir eben
nicht mehr verkraften können wir sind
jetzt über zwei jahren dieser pandemie
viele menschen haben sehr stark gelitten
gerade wenn man die kinder und
jugendlichen denken insofern ist es
genau richtig diese ressourcen an diesen
punkten einzusetzen um zum beispiel den
schulbetrieb aufrecht zu halten man muss
natürlich dann noch mal diskutieren was
macht man mit einem positiven test und
die den kontakt hatten können sie zum
beispiel in der schule oder kita bleibt
mit weiteren tests die dann intensiviert
werden also müssen nicht sozusagen
erstmal aus den ganzen betrieb hause ist
es ja ganz wichtig dass die kinder
eigentlich ein weiterbetrieb teilnehmen
können und dann ist das genau richtig
die gefahr ist ja jetzt bei diesen an
steigenden fallzahlen dass das virus in
die problematischen bereich hinein
getragen mit glücklicherweise ist das
noch nicht so dramatisch erfolgt aber
das ist ja genau das was auch der
kollege bendtner gesagt hat wenn das in
die altenpflegeheime komponenten die
krankenhäuser kommt wenn das in die
wohngruppen kommt dann kann es durchaus
wieder zu einer überlastung situation
kommen und das muss man verhindern und
das macht man in der hinsicht dass man
die ressourcen genau dort einsetzt und
eben nicht bei einem 30-jährigen
gesunden mann der eine party gefeiert
hat und schnupfen hat der bleibt zu
hause wartet bis er gesund ist und kann
sich dann selber im schnellsten mit dem
virus leben diese formulierung kommt
ihnen sehr bekannt noch vor anderthalb
jahren hat man gesagt sie kommen zur
unzeit weil man damit höchsten
infektionen zu kämpfen hatte und der
impfstoff noch nicht da war würden sie
denn jetzt sagen herr schmidt chanasit
es ist der richtige zeitpunkt eben weil
wir gar nicht anders können als mit dem
virus zu leben nur haben wir eben diese
impfquote noch nicht von spanien und von
italien ich glaube dieser satz von
henrik strikt wurde von anfang an falsch
verstanden es von anfang an richtig
gewesen er hat ihn ja auch mehrmals
erläutert was er sozusagen damit
bewirken wollte es letztendlich ein
pragmatischer umgang das wir diskutieren
in der gesellschaft und eben auch die
politik wie wir mit dem virus so umgehen
können dass wir mit dem virus leben
können weil das hat der christian
drosten auch festgestellt ist natürlich
illusorisch dass wir das virus mutieren
können das war von anfang an
sozusagen bei einer beim zwischen
erreger nicht möglich da viele tiere
ansteckt haus hier und so weiter
insofern ist das der richtige im ansatz
und ich finde das auch immer
problematisch wenn wir diese team
diskussion führen ich glaube das hat uns
gesellschaftlich einer pandemie nicht
weitergebracht ich glaube es gibt
eigentlich nur ein team nämlich das team
deutschland und das ist uns vielleicht
etwas abhanden gekommen in der panini
wir müssen alles dafür tun dass wir da
wieder sozusagen zusammenkommen in dem
team deutschland ja weil das ist
entscheidend nur damit wir es verstehen
hat mit einer könnten wir denn
weitergehen könnten wir jetzt sagen wir
gucken uns das bei den spaniern ab wir
trauen uns nein die spanier sind eben
andere infekte ist es wirklich so ein
riesiger unterschied das macht einen
unterschied gerade wenn wir auf die im
älteren mitbürgern bürger schauen gerade
die impf und genesung quote bei den über
60-jährigen da gibt es eben noch diese
lücke und wir sind gerade in der welle
das heißt der punkt dass zu diskutieren
ist jetzt wo wir müssen abwarten wie wir
durch diese welle kommen wann sie
bericht in einzelnen bundesländern sehen
ist glücklicherweise schon in bremen
dort bricht die dynamik und müssen
schauen wie sich das eben auch in den
anderen anderen bundesländern unter
anderem auch in berlin eben fortsetzen
wenn ich hatte es schon am anfang gesagt
wenn die omikron welle durch ist dann
müssen wir uns zusammensetzen die daten
anschauen und auf grundlage dieser daten
und ganz entscheidendes im wie viel
menschen haben sind genesen und geimpft
und dann können wir entscheiden welche
maßnahmen weiter fortgeführt werden
müssen ob das bevölkerungsweite
verpflichtende maßnahmen sind wurde ob
hier sozusagen stärker empfehlungen
geben und gezielte protektion also die
die auch in den nächsten jahren
gefährdet sein werden die die anwender
behandelt die krebspatienten für die
wird das nach wie vor ein problem sein
und da müssen wir nach wie vor mit
maßnahmen testen und so weiter arbeiten
in den bereichen das sagt die politische
journalistin frau klaus
kapituliert die politik im grunde
genommen vor diesem virus oder von
dieser mutation die so anstrengend ist
oder ist das pragmatismus er fühlen sie
sich jetzt auch schon in der situation
so ein bisschen lockerer zu werden
also man kann ja schon verstehen dass
sich viele politiker gerade wirklich
einer zwickmühle befinden also egal was
sie machen es könnte sich am ende als
falsch herausstellen und sie sind sicher
für viele bürger gerade einfach der
sündenbock der jetzt rand gezogen wird
und es stimmt ja auch dieser deal den
wir eigentlich alle abgeschlossen haben
der die lautete doch lässt du dich
impfen bekommst du dein normales leben
zurück und jetzt gerade mit omikron
merken wir alle für alle die sich
geimpft haben lassen merken jedenfalls
sie haben nicht nur ihr normales leben
zurückbekommen weil nach wie vor kann
man ja nicht ins fußballstadion wenn man
möchte amerikanerin hat auch nicht auf
der intensivstation genau genommen auf
hängt ja unmittelbar mit den hohen
impfquoten man ist trotzdem nicht
hundertprozentig vor dem virus geschützt
also ein kollege von mir
geburtstag und lag jetzt wirklich
richtig fies flach natürlich er schwebt
nicht in lebensgefahr und so aber dieser
dient irgendwie so in klar ist irgendwie
in doppelter hinsicht auf gekündigt
worden und natürlich gibt es da großen
frust und großes unverständnis und
natürlich ist dann die erste der erste
impuls der die politik ist schuld aber
es ist immer noch leider dieses virus
unschuldig immer wichtig ist manchmal
auch ein monstrum sieht und sagt wir
haben durch diese impfung durch all
diese maßnahmen wirklich tausende
menschenleben gerettet das muss man ja
auch mal sehen und die milden verläufe
hängen unmittelbar damit zusammen dass
wir hohe impfquoten haben und sonst
wären viele der menschen die jetzt sagen
ist ja nur ein schnupfen vielleicht auch
auf der intensivstation oder würden es
gar nicht überleben und das finde ich
muss man immer sehen dabei und deshalb
muss der fokus auch weiter aufs impfen
gehen und und das tut er und damit
kämpft man und deshalb plädiert
eigentlich auch jeder arzt und
wissenschaftler sowie so dafür dass wir
diese zahlen noch ein bisschen nach oben
trimmen herr wendt dann noch mal mit
blick auf das besondere von omikron nur
damit wir es eben wirklich richtig
einigermaßen richtig fassen die
krankenhauseinweisungen sinken also auf
den intensivstationen auf den normalen
stationen sagt jetzt die deutsche
krankenhausgesellschaft fühlt es sich
gerade wieder ein bisschen bei
steigenden
infektionen kann man sagen dass diese
beiden grafen tatsächlich auseinander
gehen und dass das ein gutes zeichen ist
also es ist so wie sie beschreiben frau
illner die
normalstation füllen sich langsam ich
kann ihn sehr konkret sagen vor einer
woche hatten wir bei uns noch 50
patienten jetzt sind es 75 das geht
schon wieder nach oben auch wenn sie die
hospitalisierung des instituts von heute
abend für die bundesrepublik betrachten
liegen wir bei ca 3 mit pfeil nach oben
aber klar die intensivstation sind nicht
so belastet vgh hatte das auch schon
dargestellt wir haben zurzeit
eben sind wir deutlich unter diesen
zahlen die verkennen 4 5000 n sie werden
in deutschland belegt das haben wir zur
zeit nicht wir haben ungefähr 2500
intensivbetten belegt das ist eine gute
nachricht aber ich warne davor wir
müssen eben auch warten es kann aus
einem normalen station patienten
intensiv patient werden das heißt das
ist noch nicht zu ende erzählt trotzdem
ich möchte auch eine positive nachricht
setzen die impfung tut auch etwas sehr
gutes ist mag bei dem einen oder anderen
der zuschauer der eindruck entstehen
dass wir machtlos hingegen omikron auch
wenn das vielleicht mild ist ich sage es
ist nicht harmlos aber die impfung die
büste
wirkt sehr wohl und das ist ganz wichtig
zu verstehen wir haben auch schon 45
prozent booster wird in deutschland das
ist toll wir haben drei viertel der
deutschen die sich haben auch impfen das
ist auch eine sehr gute nachricht wir
sind quasi auch kurz vor dem ziel ich
sage auch die indische phase kann ich
mir auch ende 22 durchaus vorstellen ich
halte es nur jetzt für den nicht
günstigen zeitpunkt dinge zu schnell zu
lockern wir sind herr söder noch mal bei
ihren gedanken vom jahreswechsel sie
haben gesagt wir müssen genauer und
verständlicher begründen was die politik
tut wie schwer ist es eigentlich wenn
wir noch so wenig wissen und wenn man
eben auch noch nicht hundertprozentig
einschätzen kann ob auch eine milde
infektion mit omikron vielleicht
langzeitschäden hinterlässt das sind
alles jahr noch dinge die wir noch nicht
genau klären parallel dazu müssen sie
entscheidungen fällen ihr vorschlag
zweig im einzelhandel hat ein gericht
jetzt erstmal weggeschlossen
weggeschossen
weise weil es da handwerkliche fehler
gab so was passiert wenn offensichtlich
auch manchmal
jedes zweite wurde hier niedersachsen
auch schon gekippt und gerichten weil es
insgesamt eine regel war die vom bund
gekommen ist wir waren von anfang an
skeptisch weil die abgrenzung zwischen
diesen alltags bereichen und anderen das
ebenfalls von anfang schwierig war
einzelnen juristischen von einzelnen
ja genau diese abgrenzung sind genau das
problem war in anderen ländern auch so
das problem aber
ich weiß jetzt noch englisch ich glaube
nicht dass bei 2
wir haben generell auch ein sehr starkes
2 geht es dem wir haben an einigen
stellen viel strengere regeln wir haben
eine konsequente fb2 masken pflicht das
haben viele andere länder nicht wir
haben von anfang an die diskus
geschlossen übrigens auch bars und
kneipen und sperrstunde in der kasse ein
unfall keine zuschauer haben umgekehrt
darf ich kurz zu ende führen haben
umgekehrt beispielsweise auch bei kultur
was auch von vielen kritisiert wird
zuschauer begrenzen also haben uns
wirklich sehr streng gehalten weil wir
auch eben besonders betroffen waren in
der welt herausforderung und mehr da
erreichen dass wir auf den sogar das
land damit den zweitniedrigsten
infektionen dann am ende jetzt
mitgeteilt die situation in der tat wie
es ist ein anspruchsvoller auf der einen
seite weil natürlich gibt es jetzt
hoffnungen es gibt auch erste
wissenschaftliche aussagen die datenlage
hilft uns etwas weil wir aus den anderen
ländern die erfahrungen annehmen können
das haben wir gerade schon ob gehört
aber natürlich hat keiner eine absolute
gewissheit deswegen ist es schon genug
dass wir auf sicht vernünftig fahren
aber eben beide dinge in die balance
bringen ich glaube schon dass es jetzt
sehr wichtig ist für viele menschen in
deutschland die halt schon erschöpft und
müde sind die darüber nachdenken die
hundertste verordnung die tausendste
einzel regeln und detail die haben mir
sehr schwer nachzuvollziehen was genau
zu begründen und auch genau zu schauen
was kommt und wie nehmen die menschen
dabei mit dass wir sie nicht verlieren
dabei meine ich jetzt nicht die
querdenker szene die zum teil auch in
einigen bereichen mit extremen hass und
hetzparolen arbeitet den müssen sagt
ganz klar
die stirn bieten aber es gibt viele
menschen im bürgerlichen lager die
einfach verunsichert sind und den müssen
wir noch besser begründen mitnehmen und
auch ein stück weit hoffnung geben so
wie wir es heute in der sendung glaube
ich auch ganz gut versuchen indem wir
uns da nicht jetzt ideologisch
diskutieren wer es der libertäre freiere
wer ist das strengere sondern einfach
relativ konsequent an den
wissenschaftlichen empfehlungen entlang
hangeln und versuchen daraus eine
konzeption zu entwickeln die nicht nur
hoffnung gibt sondern die auch in der
realität werden und tatsächlich der
unterschied ist anders als vorher mehr
geimpfte übrigens auch neue impfstoffe
die kommen und auch hoffentlich bald die
zulassung von hochwirksamen medikamenten
all das als mix zusammen gibt hoffnung
und erlaubt auch mehr möglichkeiten
worauf der bürger jetzt trifft ist kurze
stichwort es natürlich erst mal ein
ziemliches chaos pcr-test schaffen
klarheit das wissen wir sie werden nur
knapp
in berlin sind testmöglichkeiten knapp
schlange stehen zum pcr test auch wenn
man krank ist
montag schon mal zwei stunden in der
leinestraße in der schlange und wurde
dann wieder weggeschickt gestern leicht
zufällig und jetzt probiere ich zum
zweiten mal scheint irgendwie überlastet
zu sein das system
an stehen anstatt im bett zu liegen dass
müssen tausende in der praxis von
sibylle katzenstein in berlin-neukölln
testen sie im akkord
also wir testen über 300 leute am tag
und ich würde sagen das bewegt sich
irgendwas zwischen der hälfte ist
positiv wenn ich schon zwei drittel sie
schätzt rund 30 prozent aller
erkrankungen in neukölln werden allein
bei ihr erfasst die masse der fälle
könne keiner mehr nachverfolgen das haus
stürzt durch die gesellschaft durch und
die gesundheitsämter sind völlig
überlastet das heißt kontakt verfolgung
gibt es schon länger nicht mehr selbst
die erkrankten werden in aller regel
nicht angerufen katzenstein rät zuhause
bleiben bis die symptome vorbei sind
ansonsten schnell test machen und maske
tragen einfach vernünftig sein
so wenn die test jetzt noch knapper
werden werden die schlangen
wahrscheinlich auch länger ich frage mal
friedlich an herr schmidt chanasit weiß
mittlerweile jeder glauben sie wer sich
wo wann testen lassen muss naja die
regeln sind relativ komplexe uns alleine
anschauen was zwei gibt plus bedeutet
ich habe mal geschaut auf der seite von
hessen dann sind das fast über zehn
unterschiedliche konstellationen genesen
geimpft getestet
getestet also das ist eben
schwierig und dann kommen wir eben in
die lage das natürlich die pcr
kapazitäten begrenzt sind da fragt man
sich natürlich schon warum ist das in
dänemark zum beispiel im anders da sind
die kapazitäten zum 10 mal höher und wir
haben ja da auch vorschläge gemacht ich
weiß noch dass mittlerweile schon zwei
jahre her dass ich gesagt habe gerade in
der veterinärmedizin machen genau die
gleichen texte da können natürlich auch
die tests laufen hätte man massiv
natürlich auch kapazitäten schaffen
können aber ärzte mit es nicht lassen
können oder die geräte sind genau die
gleichen und gefunden können ja
natürlich der ärztlichen kollegen aber
gut es bringt uns jetzt nicht weiter es
wird genauso sein wie frau katzenstein
das gesagt hat und so wie ich das auch
schon gesagt man muss pragmatisch
vorgehen die ressourcen dort einsetzen
wo sie gebraucht werden und für diese
fälle ist eben man bleibt krank zuhause
machten schnelltest und so jetzt kommen
aber wichtige fragen und sehr praktisch
auch für unsere zuschauer herr wendler
also wir haben eine unterschiedliche
qualität den pcr test brauchen wir um
nachzuweisen dass wir infiziert sind und
nachzuweisen dass wir nicht infiziert
sind und wieder fein sind dazu reicht
dann diese anti gen test wer versteht
das
also es ist glaube ich so auch für
unsere zuschauer haben wie herr schmidt
chanasit gesagt hat man muss die
ressource pcr-test vernünftig und
priorisiert einsetzen und natürlich wir
in den kliniken und wir arbeiten ja
nicht nur in der infektiologie sondern
auch auf einer krebsstation ja wir
müssen schauen dass wir selbst wenn wir
nicht schwer erkranken dass wir kein
virus in uns tragen vielleicht keine
symptome haben aber unsere leukämie
patienten zum beispiel gefährden
deswegen gehören pcr test natürlich
primär an solche orte altenheime
pflegeheime aber jeder spieler das sieht
richtig gesagt hat der antigen
schnelltest für den 30 jährigen die
einen schnupfen hat das ist etwas das
wäre ausreichend bei symptomatischer
erkrankung schlagen diese antigen
stellte sich ja gut an das problem sind
eben personen in wohlhabenden bereichen
die müssen wirklich dann möglichst virus
freiraum sich bewegen können um andere
mitmenschen nicht zu gefährden und ich
glaube so kommen wir ein stück weit aus
diesem dilemma mit zu wenig pcr tests
momentan raus ich bin sonst bei herrn
schmidt chanasit es muss eigentlich
geschafft wenn in einem
hochindustrialisierten land wie
deutschland nicht an der ressource pcr
tests zu scheitern so inzwischen durch
wir das klären noch mal die frage rote
waren apps da dachte man ja auch man
liest nicht richtig also wir haben
irgendwie wir rote waren es leuchtet
eigentlich ständig man hat kranke
freunde kranke kinder oder auch
symptomfreie menschen die jetzt gewarnt
werden woher weiß man dann ob man
denjenigen noch mit maske oder ohne
maske begegnet ist oder macht man es
einfach aus wie mittlerweile ist er kann
auch empfiehlt sie sagt man soll
irgendwie in endstation sowieso die
wahren app ausmachen das ist das beste
nach so
dass die diesen tipp höre ich jetzt zum
ersten mal vielen dank
würdest dann sowieso nur noch los
alarmen weil da trifft man der dann
gegebenenfalls auch ganz viele und da
soll man sie ausmachen also haut dir
bist ja genau also ich meine ist ja auch
nicht schlecht wenn man ständig daran
erinnert wird vorsichtig zu sein wobei
man macht es doch mittlerweile
automatisch es ist nur wirklich ich
glaube gerade für eltern mit jüngeren
kindern mit mit schulkindern zurzeit
wirklich anstrengend weil man sich
gefühlt ständig in quarantäne befindet
mit mit einem seiner kinder und dass das
schlaucht besonders auch viele frauen
viele mütter ich habe eine bekannte die
sagt ich gebe meine kinder jetzt gar
nicht mehr in die kita weil ich komme ja
gar nicht mehr hinterher
jetzt müssen ja eltern in bayern
jedenfalls ihre kinder auch selber
testen
bevor sie sie in die kita schicken ohne
fehlen wird das zuviel
ja die sind dann halt zu hause aber wer
kann sich das leisten natürlich nicht
alle und was macht das mit den kindern
was macht das auch mit frauenkarrieren
wenn sich jetzt wieder so auf diese
unbegrenzte ressource weibliche kunst
verlassen es werde sowieso
also dann musik die frage ist erstens
wie priorisieren aber wir hatten wie
priorisieren die schlangen sind deshalb
der vgv weil ist unentgeltliche test
sind wenn man es denn sicher wissen
möchte dann muss man selber bezahlen
wird denn dafür auch noch kapazität
vorgehalten am pc rt reisen ganz
grundsätzlich sie haben ja nach
konzepten gefragt wie jetzt umgehen und
es braucht drei dinge 1 haben wir schon
die geänderten quarantäne regeln die ja
vor allen dingen dem schutz der
kritischen infrastruktur denn jetzt muss
folgen darüber schon gesprochen die
veränderten kontakt nachverfolgung die
fokussierung und das dritte ist wir
brauchen ein verändertes test regime das
heißt wirklich priorisierung der pcr
tests auf die wohlhabenden bereiche auf
die krebsstation oder eben die
eigenheime pflegeheime und ansonsten
braucht es eben verlässliche antigens
nettes die auch dann anerkannt werden
als genesenen nachweis und auch beim
arbeitgeber dafür braucht es eine neue
test verordnung die informationen die
wir haben ist dass der
gesundheitsminister am sondert also
übermorgen eine solche test verordnung
vorlegen wird und ich gehe davon aus
dass das dann auch bestandteil der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
diskussionen und beschlüsse wird dass
man eben fokussiert und dann hat man
auch eine antwort auf diese schlangen
wenn nicht mehr jeder mit einem pcr-test
weiteren sondern sondern dort die pcr
tessin wo sie gebraucht werden und
ansonsten man mit den antiken schnitt
ist also drei dinge quarantäne regen
umsätzen kontakt nachverfolgung
fokussieren test regime verändern so
machen dass das adäquat und sinnvoll ist
und ansonsten kitas und schulen offen
halten damit paar gräser kräuter und auf
die kritische infrastruktur auf rädern
wird jetzt ist alles wieder auf volle
hand würde ich sagen und sofort ist
markus söder dran
söder wir sind bei der frage konnte man
diesen mangel nicht absehen regiert
jetzt praktisch wieder der mangel wir
erinnern uns wie es die masken schlecht
geredet wurde sie dann hatten jetzt
haben wir die schnelltests lange
schlecht geredet und haben gesagt sie
sind zu 40 prozent unsicher und jetzt
brauchen wir sie wieder weil wir nicht
genug pcr tests haben also klassische
frage hätten wir das früher wissen
können und uns vielleicht schon mal ein
bisschen früher und pcr tests müssen
wir haben im moment noch keine ganz
akute not in bayern obwohl wir diese
testpflicht beispielsweise in der kita
gerade auf wunsch der eltern und viele
viele frauen eingeführt haben mit dem
ich die kinder sicher sind und her nicht
gefährdet sind wir gerade bei den
kleinen gab es am anfang auch bei uns
sehr viele unsicherheiten und wir finden
es übrigens auch gerade nach rücksprache
mit vielen erzieherin in bayern besser
wenn die eltern die selber machen können
als wenn es in der kita gab bei den
klein gemacht werden soll weil es doch
über das anders ist das wenn es 1 15
oder 16 jährigen der schule macht aber
zurück sie habe in der tat recht es gibt
ja viel verwirrung allein schon deswegen
weil der debatte gab welche antigen
stellte ist überhaupt wirksam sind ja
auch wirksam sind bei omikron weil wir
da zum teil sehr unterschiedliche
ergebnisse haben da hat der bund jetzt
ja gesagt der bundesgesundheitsminister
er will da eine liste vorlegen der die
besonders wirksam und auch treffsicher
sind eine genaue justierung sondern weil
das ist nämlich schon die voraussetzung
dafür denn man dafür nicht vergessen
wenn in vielen bereichen zweig plus
herrscht dann heißt spielt dieser test
hier eine rolle auch um die sicherheit
zu haben vor der ansteckung also muss
das immer genau geklärt werden welche
texte sind dann in der tat welche test
wo für wen vorgeschrieben sind wie herrn
professor benton beispielsweise sagte
halte das für sinnvoll um dies dann
umzusetzen aber wir haben jetzt noch
nicht die akute problematik aber
natürlich so wenn irgendwann einmal die
zahlen weiter so dynamisch steigen ins
doppelte hineingehen bei der
verdoppelung dann ist es sicherlich mit
der test kapazität schwierig dann ist es
schwierig ich habe vergessen sie zu
fragen nach der kontakt nach verfolgung
luca app muss im april auch in bayern
verlängert werden sagen sie wie andere
staaten auch das brauchen wir nicht mehr
das schaffen wir nicht mehr das hat sich
sowieso erledigt
ja es wird relativ wenig genutzt
aktion und hat sich durch andere fragen
auch tatsächlich etwas überholt wird
bewerten ist gerade das
gesundheitsministerium monster getan ist
er machen eine empfehlung aber es könnte
durchaus sein dass wir den weg der
anderen bundesländer an der stelle
folgen die haben insgesamt über 5000
leute so sagt mir der
gesundheitsminister im einsatz
beispielsweise bei der kontakt nach
verfolgung auch das funktioniert noch da
war auch das stößt wiegands nur in der
tat bestätigen das stößt irgendwann die
grenzen vor allem stellt sich ja
tatsächlich die entscheidende frage noch
einmal und das ist ja die die grundlage
jeden handelns wäre micon zu gefährlich
wie delta da müssen wir ganz anders
agieren wenn aber es so bleibt bei den
milden verläufen dann kommt es darauf an
dass wir nochmal ein die besonders
denken und auch im herangehen die
ungeschützt sind denn in der tat ist es
so bei ungeimpften kann omikron ähnliche
wirkung und vielleicht entfachen kann
ähnliche folgen sein und da müssen wir
noch mal ansetzen so lange wir die
impfpflicht noch nicht haben auch das
impfen dort zu verstärken um die
schutzwirkung zusammen und erzählen weiß
holen gesagt habe nochmal ein neuer
impfstoff für den sollten wir jetzt auch
werben und vielleicht helfen dass damit
auch noch der eine andere sich
zusätzlich im pflaster und die kommen
und sie kommen mitte februar wenn ich
nicht irre hoffentlich wir sind bei
einem nächsten aufreger dieser tage herr
wentner es ist plötzlich die genesenen
zeit pauschal gekürzt worden und zwar
von 6 also der genießen schutz und zwar
von sechs monaten auf drei monate leider
auch nur durch eine veröffentlichung des
lka ist festgelegt worden dass genesene
also delta genesene eben nicht mehr
sechs monate sich frei bewegen können
sondern nur noch drei was löst das aus
was löst ist auch bei ihnen
beispielsweise im krankenhaus
ich will dass zunächst wissenschaftlich
bewerten dass es so dass das lka eine
entscheidung getroffen hat auf der basis
dass delta genießen sondern nicht sie
jetzt mal
nach drei monaten plus fix sie sich mit
omikron infizieren konnten
also die der immunschutz eines genesen
nicht so lange anhielt und man hat
sozusagen den analogie schloss geführt
dass auch ein omikron infizierter
möglicherweise nach drei monaten sich
durch eine vielleicht andere variante
infizieren könnten deswegen diese
vorsichtsmaßnahmen mit den drei monaten
vielleicht ist die kommunikation nicht
ganz glücklich gelaufen man hätte das
auch vielleicht in der
bundespressekonferenz
zusammen mit torsten noch mal
diskutieren können aber das sei
dahingestellt aber in der in der sache
kann man kann man dem folgen das heißt
natürlich auch wenn sie jetzt nach der
klinik fragen was mitarbeiterschaft
angeht das hier natürlich auch ein
gewisser gesagt mal kick nochmal kommt
sich postern zu lassen weil eben der
gelesenen status früher sozusagen
erlischt und das wird insgesamt die
poster kampagne nochmal stimulieren das
ist sozusagen ein guter nebeneffekt
dieser dieser initiative gut nun ist ein
teil von denen kollegen gegebenenfalls
auch schon gewusst hat und sicherer kann
man doch eigentlich nicht sein wenn man
durch eine in anführungsstrichen
natürliche infektion gegangen ist und
gepustet ist
ja da muss ich ihnen widersprechen
trainer es gibt daten aus südafrika die
durchaus zeigen dass omikron infizierte
keinen ausreichenden schutz haben das
sind natürlich zunächst mal
laborexperimente aber zum beispiel auch
die data variante wird dann nicht
neutralisiert man müsse davon ausgehen
dass auch andere varianten
daneben entsprechend nicht neutralisiert
werden deswegen diese
fragen
gibt es für diesen sprung von sechs
monaten auf drei monate genießen den
schutz zustand oder status eine gute
begründung also ich glaube kollege
wänden hat das schon gesagt hätte
kommunikativ besser laufen sie sich
jetzt müssen viele leute impfen lass
genau weil es eben von heute auf morgen
passiert ist oder eben gerade auch in
anderen europäischen ländern ganz andere
regelungen haben die ja genau die
gleichen wissenschaftlichen daten haben
und dann zu anderen erkenntnissen kommen
das
führt zu fragen die ich vollkommen
nachvollziehen kann und ich glaube da
würde ich jetzt in dem fall auch den
kollegen ein bisschen widersprechen das
ist nicht schlimm das ist ja eine
lebendige diskussion das eigentlich da
die wirklich solide datengrundlage
fehlten also es ist sehr schnell
entschieden worden meines erachtens man
hätte sich damit auch noch zeit lassen
können und noch weitere daten abwarten
und das führt aber eben wie gesagt bei
vielen vielen menschen zu problemen weil
sie genau diesen zweig plus status zum
teil verlieren was machen die
grenzpendler in der schweiz in zwölf
monate in frankreich sechs monate bei
uns drei monate ich glaube dass es gut
wenn das harmonisiert wäre und wie
gesagt die wissenschaftlichen daten sind
weltweit die gleichen die bewertet
werden insofern würde man sich das
glaube ich auch als bürger und
bürgerinnen ist sie haben das jetzt auch
noch nicht nachvollziehen können warum
das lka idee so entschieden ich habe das
im gegensatz zu entwenden ich habe das
mir natürlich auch an angeschaut auch
die studien die dort zitiert werden
meines erachtens ergibt sich daraus
nicht diese schlussfolgerung das heißt
noch mal zurück gefragt herr wentner
denken sie dass es denn da auch noch mal
bewegung in eine andere richtung geben
könnte wenn man eben durch welche daten
auch immer nachweis dass genesene
tatsächlich diesen schutz auch länger
haben
es ist prinzipiell möglich
ist es so dass die datenlage nicht sehr
füllig ist da der spieler sind schon
recht und es ist vielleicht eine sehr
schnelle entscheidung gewesen
aber wie gesagt es hat ja auch den
nebeneffekt durch eine musterung
für ich ja keinen schaden zu das heißt
also die puste raum per se ist ja auch
eine sehr harte qualys mittel und die
buskampagne wird ohne zweifel auch durch
diese entscheidung stimuliert und dann
sind hier noch mal bei der politik herr
söder und fragen nach diesen neuen
quarantäne regeln haben sie denn da das
gefühl dass sie wirklich auch festen
fußes sagen können jeder gepostete muss
überhaupt nicht mehr in quarantäne weil
er auch vor einer infektion geschützt
ist das fragen sich auch viele leute wie
wir das eigentlich
nachweisen können und ob es nicht auch
eine infektion möglichkeit selbst bei
den gebuchten gibt die wir jetzt von
einem tag auf den anderen mit einer
quarantänezeit 0 bedenken
nun werden die entscheidung getroffen
kreiste ministerin auf empfehlung der
bundesregierung und auch die experten
gehen und wir verlassen uns da relativ
streng und strikte richten wir uns dann
auch was seine empfehlung kommt und
wurde dies als sinnvoll erachtet auch
von den gesundheitsministern weil die
verkürzung der quarantäne unter anderem
mit der geschwindigkeit von omikron aber
auch mit der ansteckung varianz zu tun
hat also das omikron schneller wirkt und
dass deswegen die ansteckung auch anders
einzustufen sei gerade ist der eine teil
bei dem anderen teil wenn ich das noch
anmerken dass ich fand es auch ein
bisschen unglücklich und wenig
nachvollziehbar warum jetzt der genese
des staates gekürzt und welche
begründungen da waren ich habe leider
die studien nicht lesen können aber es
hat uns alle etwas überrascht und ist
tatsächlich stellt ist viele genesene
für eine völlig neue situation
wenn das motiv sei dass euch alle mehr
noch mal zusätzlich poster lassen dann
müsste hätte man das aber erklären
müssen also schien es vielen als nicht
gerechtfertigt und deswegen das meinte
ich übrigens auch zu beginn der sendung
wo sie gefragt haben was habe ich mir da
überlegt oder warum habe ich dann
nachgedacht dafür entsprechend glaubt
schon dass diese begründungspflicht
heute viel intensiver und breiter sein
muss als sie noch vor einem jahr davor
anhalt war obwohl wir tatsächlich nicht
wen ich in jeder hinsicht schon viel
wissen frau kiefer ich formuliere es mal
so
physik haben da sicherlich auch
überraschend oder haben sie verstanden
warum der gesundheitsminister und das
lka das jetzt so festlegen für uns kam
es auch überraschend es ist nun so ich
kann ihnen nur sagen dass wir sehr
zufrieden sind mit der entwicklung die
das bus dann nimmt also wie gesagt wir
sind jetzt werden sehr zügig auf über
die hälfte der berliner und berliner
kommen die gebucht sind das ist
natürlich gut ich glaube es ist wichtig
jetzt den fokus darauf zu legen die
leute auch zu motivieren sich postern zu
lassen weil die sicherheit dann größer
als weil man einfachere möglichkeiten
hat zweig plus ist klar definiert
entweder gewusst hat oder getestet und
ich finde das kann man erklären und das
muss man erklären und das führt dazu
dass menschen sich auf postern lassen
und ich finde es aber auch wichtig dass
man eben sagt das ist jetzt nicht nur
irgendein anreiz sondern es ist
tatsächlich ja auch so dass diejenigen
die gepustet sind einen höheren schutz
der meere jetzt festgelegt dass die in
einem haushalt mit einem infizierten
zusammen sein dürfen und auch
weiterarbeiten dürfen das hat ja alles
auch konsequenzen und man fragt sich
natürlich gibt es tatsächlich diese
überzeugung dass wir das genauso machen
können oder ist das auch ein ziemlicher
ritt auf der rasierklinge wenn ich in
ihre augen gucken würde ich vermuten sie
denken so richtig sie eigentlich so sehr
der punkt ist doch einfach die
gelockerten oder etwas verminderten
karrieristen und regeln hatten doch auch
ein ganz wesentliches ziel nämlich dafür
zu sorgen dass all das was
daseinsvorsorge versorgung der
bevölkerung kritische infrastruktur
wasser strom ernährung lebensmittel
logistik alter aber die mehrheit bleibt
ja aber dass der punkt ist doch wenn sie
weiter diese quarantäne regeln wie
bisher aufrecht erhalten will und dann
hätten wir jetzt mit diesem fall seien
wirklich schon ganz andere situationen
und nicht zehn bis 15 prozent ausfallen
der kritischen infrastruktur sondern
viel höher und es wird dann kritisch
wenn die kritische infrastruktur sei
also die klassische versorgung mit
wasser strom lebensmittel und und
gesundheitlichen diensten wenn das eben
20 30 prozent wegbricht dann wird es
problematisch dass muss man verhindern
und deswegen ist eben diese veränderten
quarantäne und verstanden haben wir
wollen nur wissen wie sich ja und
natürlich gibt es immer bei all diesen
dingen ein restrisiko das ist doch klar
sieht man auf wir haben menschen die
sind gebucht hat und wohin sich die
krankheit trotzdem und deswegen ist eben
diese vorsicht die man selber weiten
lässt auch in seinem eigenen verhalten
wird einfach weiter nötig sanken sogar
zweimal können die sich infizieren
insofern voraus wir haben diese